is it really selfish for me to hope that
this new Ghostbusters is a hit primarily
so that replicas of props from the
original series aren't monstrously
expensive and hard to get a hold of
anymore
ah new Ghostbusters it's happening it's
happening in the summer and we have a
first trailer if you're curious as to my
initial reaction of it I did an actual
reaction video over in the break room
of geek so feel free to check that out
I'm still doing this here because I had
I wanted to take the time to gather my
thoughts a little bit more I and I did
something I almost never do I took notes
so I don't generally do this generally
when I talk about trailers on here I
watch it and maybe watch it a second
time and then just sit down and ramble
it out this one I did something I almost
never do i sat down and I watched it
like four or five times pausing as it
went taking notes noting down what it
was that I was seeing that I wanted to
be sure to talk about and I'm going to
reference those notes because yeah look
the original Ghostbusters is my favorite
film of all time period end of sentence
so I am really wanting to dig into the
fact that I found a lot to like in this
trailer and the more I thought about
what I was seeing the more I liked it
and the more I caught on subsequent
secondary views that I didn't catch up
my first one that I did the reaction to
the more I'm kind of like they're coming
at this from a good space doesn't
guarantee it'll be good but they're
coming at this from a strong space so
I'm actually gonna go through my notes
and these were prime these are primarily
done in the order that you know things
occurred in the trailer so let's see so
start setting completely different we've
got a very rural setting here which the
at first I was like that's almost kind
of the antithesis of ghostbusters isn't
it a big part of the thing of
Ghostbusters was doing these sort of
haunted house kind of things you know
the supernatural stuff in the middle of
a city things like that don't happen in
the middle of the city which is true but
then you think about what Ghostbusters
became and how ubiquitous it began I'm
not gonna say it started a trend but
certainly within franchise that's all
that's ever been outside of like a few
episodes of like the cartoon or maybe
some comic book issues so taking even
though the idea of you know ghosts in a
spooky rundown farm not exactly new it
is new for this franchise and we
actually haven't really seen the
Ghostbusters approach to a more
traditional haunted house kind of
setting like this rundown farmhouse
looks to be in this you know more sort
of isolated town is so Wow in and of
itself that's insetting is not unique
for a ghost story
it is unique for a ghost story with
Ghostbusters in it so odd the more I
actually thought about that because
initially you threw me off that they
weren't into major city but then I was
like okay like especially we're doing
this whole rediscovering thing and it's
not just a case of we're seeing you know
the business still up and running I you
know if they're not doing that and
they're clearly not it makes sense to
shake up the setting a bit more in this
way what else have I got okay so the
whole thing with earthquakes I'm kind of
running through the town that's kind of
neat guys first of all earthquakes
they're just good as harbingers so
that's cool and that they're well
thought out and I also kind of like that
it makes though the threat at least as
far as what we see in the trailer feel
very localized now it's possible this
could still blow up into a though you
the world is at stake thing I really
hope it doesn't because they could just
keep it localized and like the forces
here are gonna tear just this town apart
that'll be fine especially if we're
dealing with young kids in way over the
heads that's a perfectly fine level of
stakes and that's the vibe I'm getting
so I'm hoping they don't overshoot the
threat level so they are bringing back
the idea that the Ghostbusters have more
has been forgotten and ghosts aren't
really a thing anymore and one of these
days I will do a video detailing my
issues with ghostbusters 2 in probably
way more detail than anybody knows but
that is one of the things that I don't
like about Ghostbusters 2 I will admit
that it makes a fair amount of
logistical sense as far as the lore of
Ghostbusters goes because in that
original film it is actually made pretty
explicitly clear that ghostly activity
is up significantly in anticipation of
gozer so once that was dealt with it
makes sense that everything died off and
then Ghostbusters 2 it kind of came back
up again when Vigo was trying to come
back through and then it would make
sense that it petered out again
basically it's kind of been established
that ghostly activity is not
particularly high like it's a very low
background level unless there's
something going on that's artificially
sort of jacking it up something like
Gozer or Vigo and keeping with that in
mind it does make sense that you know
the Ghostbusters have kind of been
forgotten a little bit and it felt it
felt like a very meta moment
actually when Paul Rudd who I like I'm
not like oh Paul Rudd like I feel like a
lot of people in my generation are but
no he's cool I like him he's enjoyable
but it felt like a meta moment kind of
when he picks up the the trap but he's
like oh great replica and like these
younger kids alike replicas of what and
I totally felt for Paul Rudd of like you
don't you don't know but like this was
the most awesome stuff you know it's a
ghost trap you you don't you why don't
you know that this is awesome
so I feel like they get they get a bit
of that sort of cross generational
geekery stuff that didn't carry over to
the next generation of geeks moment to
there a little bit which is kind of cool
and I like it but coming back to that
overall idea that things have died down
again again on principle I don't really
care for it but again looking at the
circumstances under which this movie is
being made which is a dearth of then
like it'll have been 31 years since
Ghostbusters 2 came out that this is
in continuity with that so bearing that
in mind this probably makes the most
sense to do as far as if they're gonna
pick it up again and go with the
storyline that they're going with so
while I don't love it here I actually
feel like it's a acceptable choice
whereas with ghostbusters 2 I felt like
there was no good reason for that to
have been the case so there's that um Oh
hmm there was a great moment I forget I
think it was right after like the the
trap like a little stuff kind of came
out and Paul where I dropped it before
before piano notes do DeeDee uh I know
those piano notes so well they're from
the original film and I I can even tell
you the exact moment that those piano
notes are hit it's when they're down in
the library basement looking for that
original librarian ghost and they're
like listen did you smell something ah
there are things that hit me right in
the nostalgia fields and that was one
and they were surprisingly subtle things
for the most part with one exception
I'll get to that but that that made me
happy so this establishes pretty cleanly
I did pick up on my reaction but I
didn't catch all the hints because I was
looking at on my phone so I didn't have
you know a wider view of the whole thing
but this is absolutely Egan's
granddaughter and this is Egan's falling
apart house she's down in this it's a
basement or it's something and there's a
collection of spores molds and fungus
and I did not catch that on the first
watching and I'm not gonna lie and his
guys sound really stupid I choked up a
little seeing that when I caught it on
my second viewing of the trailer Oh God
it is really sad that Harold Ramis
is gone and he was not only good in
these movies he was just he was great he
was a wonderful director and I kind of
liked that by half
this be his granddaughter having this
house be something that was left to them
and effectively make it his legacy
it makes the death of Egon not be an
incidental thing that they have to
account for and coverage as to explain
why an actor can't appear in any way
shape or form but instead making it
court of the plot seems far more
respectful an acknowledgment of how
important Harold during this was to this
story because he didn't just play Egon
he co-wrote the scripts he was really
integral to this thing so I the level of
respect I feel that this approach gives
to him or to him by proxy of his
character is was a really wonderful
thing and I honestly kind of find it
touching so that was really cool and I
also like that they didn't say it in the
trailer I'm sure they'll say it in the
movie but I like that they didn't say it
in the trailer it's just who are you
anyway she's pushing the jumpsuit aside
there it is Spengler oh that's really
good I mean I think that's a good idea
for the story and as far as constructing
the trailer that was really good okay so
moving on from that okay so we have the
really blatant a nostalgia hit which I
was both resentful of but also admit
that it worked which was the pulling of
the line from Peter call it fates call
dad luck call it karma and it sounded
slightly weird broken up the way that
they did it but the fact that it sounded
we're meant that I immediately
recognized that is the original line
delivery from the original Ghostbusters
I mentioned this in my reaction video
but the the trailer for force awakens
did something slightly similar by having
Luke's line forces strong is is strong
in my family my father has you know I
have it and the thing was in that it
though that line was from Return of the
Jedi they had Mark Hamill
you could hear how the vocal quality was
different and the intonation was
slightly different if you are someone
like me and wash these movies
obsessively and have to completely
memorize down to the exact cadence and
pause between any word that was said
uh-huh so I immediately caught that that
was a rerecord line there so immediately
caught that this was directly pulled in
from the original and like I said it was
a cheap shot
but it still worked so kudos but I say
that with a grimace it's one of those
things that like I'm ashamed to admit
that worked on me I wish it didn't but
yeah it did um Oh
tiny thing I really like especially the
more that I thought about it there's
this moment Paul Rudd's in this car and
like this this clawed foot like thud on
the hood of the car I like that
cuz that's a monster and that's
something to remember about Ghostbusters
like we remember Slimer and you know
Stay Puft but there were real tangible
monsters especially in that first one I
mean the terror dogs and just things
could be more visceral and monstrous
than just you know the ethereal floating
ghosts and I like that this appears to
have remembered that which is very good
because I think that was that it didn't
occur to me before but I think that
might have been one of the things that
the the Ghostbusters reboot kind of
dropped the ball on it was like it was
all just ghosts that's really all that
was going on from top to bottom and you
know that's fine and all but you know
the original film brought in a lot more
than just the ghosts so I like that this
appears to have remembered that and I'm
kind of I'm down for that
the gunner seat that was kind of cool
and it's the kind of thing that like I
imagined the Ghostbusters would have
added to xo1 at some point between
ghostbusters 2 and whenever they just
stopped doing what they were doing so
that was neat so there was the ghost
that they appear to be chasing it
through the streets and I got concerned
on my first year again looking at it on
a phone because he looked
Slimer esque it's not Slimer I you know
I went through this thing you know I
frame-by-frame dat a few point first of
all this one's blue and while it is
generally shaped a bit like Slimer
overall if you in a few moments are you
able to bond us together semi-decent
good look at the face it's definitely a
distinctly different design so they did
not just bring back Slimer for no
frickin reason cuz that that that would
have ticked me off
but they didn't do it huh who um I think
I almost kind of would have preferred if
they'd gone with a ghost design that was
not even really particularly reminiscent
of Slimer if they'd gone with something
you know maybe more thin and wispy as
opposed to you know the sort of bulbous
shape that he is but I can roll with it
as long as it's not him and it wasn't so
that was a relief I'm trying to think of
if there was anything else the trailer
did kind of lack a strong ending note it
just ends with the ecto-1 skidding to a
halt but that wasn't a big moment cuz
we'd already seen ecto-1 driving at a
few points up up to then so you know it
it wasn't the strongest closing moment
but that's not an issue with the film
that's an issue with the trailer and the
one other thing I'll talk about because
again I talked about it in my reaction
the idea of having it be young kids
initially might but now also keep in
mind as I'm talking about this I have
gone out of my way to not try and dig
into and go through rumours or leaks or
like I don't want to know what ton about
this story before I know about it so I'm
sure there's some stuff that has been
confirmed and like the fact that this
was a gangs relatives has probably been
leaching confirmed by other people
elsewhere but I'm avoiding all that crap
which I'm glad because like I said I got
that ah catching the spores molds and
fungus and picking up on that on my own
that was a good feeling but anyways as
far as the kids go my initial thought
was it doesn't have to be kids like
because I know ghostbusters have always
appealed to kids it appealed to me as a
kid I mean that's a big part of why it's
my favorite movie of all time I grew up
on that movie I'd love it to death and I
have since I was very very young but
I always kind of push back on the what
feels like very corporate way I'm
thinking of kids will like it more if we
put kids in it which is you know the
mentality they you know got Robin and
and Bucky inserted into the early comics
and the lens and lends itself to kids
sidekicks it's why you know they were
things like scrappy-doo or you know
there were actually you know these
annoying kid proxies and the later
seasons of the Real Ghostbusters and
they I will always push back on that cuz
I at least for my experience when I was
a kid and I wanted to pretend and play
Ghostbusters I imagined I was a
Ghostbuster or I was Indiana Jones or I
was a Jedi I wasn't a kid sidekick or a
kid who like was with no like but as
much as that sort of my initial gut
reaction to seeing kids filling these
roles I think it's another thing that
under the circumstances that we have
might have been the best idea so it kind
of gets filed under the similar
situation of the the more rural setting
because what were the other options if
they were going to tie this directly
into the original continuity option
number one bring back the original cast
now last I was aware and again I'm not
going to dig through and find out
because I don't want to know in advance
but last I was aware the surviving cast
is going to feature in some way shape or
form so they are going to be on hand but
like we've all seen Kingdom of the
Crystal Skull there there is a point
where if a torch is not going to be
properly passed it's not fun seeing your
heroes be old and crotchety it's really
hard to thread the needle on doing that
and I I think having a film be primarily
about them would have been a mistake and
would have felt very just awkward so
other alternative would have been to you
know have a new team of people say
around the age that the original team
was
when they first formed the business but
I think doing that it it really does you
can't escape the fact that you're
dealing with replacements where this
would have been the original cast if
they were young enough to still be doing
it
but because they're not here's these
jokers instead by having it be kids it
it forces way less of a comparison and
you're not gonna be looking for the Egon
the Peter the Ray the Winston of the
group because it's a it's a group of
young kids two of them appear to be
siblings it's a completely different
dynamic you're not gonna do a one to one
comparison which means you're not going
to be you know automatically against
these kids because like oh well you're
like this character who I like more why
can't I have them and having it just be
just breaking that structure and doing
something as different as this versus
what you know the core team was before
does a good job of connecting it to that
without all the baggage that comes with
if you try and if you try and attach it
while also recreating it at the same
time Jason Reitman is a very intelligent
director and I think he appears to have
approach to this with a very mindful eye
because I think more than anything the
big failing of Paul phigs
ghostbusters which the 2016 ghostbusters
I don't hate the way a lot of people
hate it but it's not great but I think
the major failing of it is that it
approached it as just you know a comedy
when ghostbusters the reason it's great
is because yes it's funny but it's also
inventive and kind of scary and it it
takes what it what it's doing actually
pretty dang seriously and having all of
that fit together in a way that is
fairly deadpan aside from literally one
character and that's Peter that was a
big part of what knit all of that
together and puffy just kind of went out
and made a comedy and it wasn't DC
comedy but it lacks the other elements
this it didn't it didn't feel as fully
thought-out as the original Ghostbusters
no to be fair these second Ghostbusters
didn't feel as thought-out as the
original Ghostbusters again I'll do that
video one of these days but this what
I'm picking up from the trailer and
especially now that I've watched it
several times I've really thought about
it
this feels very thought through and very
deliberate and it does not feel like
choices were made just because it feels
like choices were made with the thought
about what that implies and what that
says and that more than anything gives
me hope and I oh my god I'm actually
kind of just slightly nervously but
excited to see this I was not expecting
that I want to like it of course I do
but knowing my love of the original and
knowing that I haven't liked any of the
other sequels or reboot and really not
much of anything aside from the best
episodes of the Real Ghostbusters it
really is just that first film for the
most part the more I think about what I
see for this the more I'm like oh crap
this might actually work yeah that's
that's weird
ghostbusters afterlife first trailer
what you think whatever your thoughts
are drop something down the comments
let's talk about it if you could support
me on my patreon page tis the season to
be generous I sure as heck would
appreciate it also I've got a P o box if
you want to send me stuff but beyond
that like subscribe share this share the
growing enthusiasm and joy almost a new
Ghostbusters I never thought I'd feel
that this is cool or you know you don't
have to do any of that I mean you may be
yeah but at the end of the day folks
you're the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this
so is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]